ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะ
คุณเรียมค่าสบายดีไหมคะ
สบายดีค่ะตรงวันนี้ร้อนนิดนึงน้อยขอ
กรุงเทพฯก็ร้อน
ร้อนอุ้ยมอยส์และก็คิดว่าคิดว่าอีกหน่อย
ฝนจะตก
ฝนใช้วัดจะตกเพราะว่ามีมดมดหน้ากูเรียม
ช่วยว่ารูปมดได้ไหมคะหมดเป็นแบบนี้ฆ่า
มด
มีมดเดิน
มากๆอ่ะมีมดเดินมากๆก็เลยคิดว่าอาจจะวัน
นี้พรุ่งนี้ฝนจะตกนะคะเพราะว่าร้อนมา 2
วันแล้วนะฮะเอารายการร้อนวันนี้ร้อนพรุ่ง
นี้ฝนตกคลิปคุยคิดนะคะ
เตรียมดูทีวี
เขาบอกว่าจะมีพายุ
โง่ใครอยู่เข้าวันที่
15 วันที่ 15 ให้ค่ะก็วันนี้วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะพี่เอ็นที่ 14 ค่ะงูวันนี้วันที่ 14
14 นะฮะพรุ่งนี้มีพายุ
ใช่ไหมโอ้วันนี้วันที่ 14 วันอะไรคะ
วันที่ 14 เป็นวันจันทร์ค่ะวันจันทร์นะคะ
วันจันทร์วันที่ 14 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมเดือนมีนาคมปีพตทเท่าไหร่คะพ.ศ
[เพลง]
2565  2566
ปีปีคศเท่าไหร่คะข้อ
2022 ค่ะแต่ค.ศ 2020  2 โอเคอ่อนพรุ่ง
นี้ไม่ร้อนคุณเรียม
พรุ่งนี้อยู่ข้างเรา
พายุเข้าฝนตกนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะคุณเรียมคลิปที่แล้วอ่ะเราคุยอะไร
กันนะ
รึยังทิศที่แลปคุยกันเรื่องหนังที่เรียม
ชอบเรื่องราแลนด์แล้วก็พี่เอกบอกว่าพี่
ชอบหนังเรื่องซิป
mn บอกใช่ๆปิดคูเรียมก็อยากรู้ใช่ไหม
ใช่เขาว่าเลียมดูหนังดูหนังยีสต์หน่อย
คุณครูเอกครูเห็นอ่ะชอบดูหนังไหมคะอ่า
อย่างคลิปที่แล้วที่คุยกันน่ะเพราะว่าครู
เรียมดูหนังนิดหน่อยอ่ะแต่ก็เราก็ได้คุย
เกี่ยวกับหนังเรื่องนั้นว่าเป็นยังไงหนัง
เรื่องลาลาแลนด์ซึ่งเป็นหนังเศร้าใช่ไหม
คู่เอกแล้วก็ไม่เข้าใจทำไมเลิกคู๋จะไม่ดู
ผู้ a ไม่ชอบดูหนังเลิกกันนะฮะกูเอกจะไม่
ชอบแต่ว่าครูเอกชอบดูเรื่อง The  fifth
Element
ให้เรียบร้อยไปดูดูครั้ง
ให้มันหมายถึงครั้งติดๆกันเลยนะคุยชอบมาก
หนู
คูณเรียนบอกว่าลาลาแลนด์เป็นหนังสวยใช่
ไหมให้สวยกับหนูอ่าวีดีโอสวย
ทุกอย่างดูแล้วสวย
ขึ้นโดยเม้นน่ะตรงข้าม
อ้าวไม่มีอะไรสวยเลยแล้วทำไมพี่เอ๋เอ๋ชอบ
มีผู้หญิงสวย 1 คน
1 คน 1 คนเลยนะเดี๋ยวจะเล่าให้คุณเรียม
ฟังเดี๋ยวกูเองขอแชร์สกรีนนะคะ
คุยขอ Share  screen ก่อน
อะไรอ่ะทำไม
อะ cancel นะคะเดี๋ยวจะเล่าให้ครูเรียม
ฟังเกี่ยวกับเรื่อง The  fifth  Element
มีผู้หญิง 1 คน
ใช่คงอยากจะต้องหนี
เรื่องน้องเกิดอะไรขึ้นค่ะพี่เอ๋คือ
เรื่องนี้มีอยู่เกี่ยวกับโลกคูเรียร์เอ่อ
โลก
อ่าอันนี้ประเทศไทย
[เพลง]
แต่เรื่องนี้ไม่ใช่ในประเทศไทยเนาะคิดที่
ไหนไม่รู้ที่ไหนกูอาจจะไม่ได้ที่ไหนแต่
ไม่เช่นโรคปี 2002
เป็นปีไหนคะ
อนาคต
อาจจะปี 3,000
โรคข้อสอบใช่โลกอนาคตราคาเขาบอกว่าโลก
เนี่ยมันจะมีดาวมันก็มีดาวอ่ะค่ะ
ดาวที่นี้มันมีดาวดาวเนี่ยถ้าดาวน์ดาวน์
จะอยู่ข้างนอกข้างนอกโลกใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
ดาวจะอยู่นอกโลกค่าดาวมองเห็นไหมมองเห็น
หน้าอ่ะดาว
ตกลงมาเนี่ยนะดาวแล้วก็ตกลงมาถ้าดาวตก
เล็กๆน่ะ
ชอบไปหาโพเรี่ยมเวลาเห็นดาวตก
เออเวลาเห็นดาวตกผู้เรียนทำอาโต้
แล้วตกแล้วก็อธิษฐาน
ขอให้ขออะไร
ฉลาดเธอหา
ขออะไรก็ได้แต่เป็นคนไทยจริงๆนะจะเอาตก
เพิ่มชี้และชี้ไม่ได้นะ
ไม่ครับดาวตกที่ได้ตกออกคนไทยบอกชี้ไม่
ได้คนไทยล่ะคนไทยบอกว่า
คนไทยบอกว่าเนื้อเป็นเป็นเทวดา
[เพลง]
เทวดาหน้าตายจากสวรรค์นะคะอ่ะเขาเรียกว่า
จุติจุติจากสวรรค์ลงมาลงมาที่โลกแล้วก็
อาจจะมีผู้หญิงคนนึงกำลังจะท้องก็จะมา
เข้าที่ท้องผู้หญิงแต่ถ้า
เทวดาตกใจไม่ไปท้องผู้หญิงไปท้อง
หมาค่ะเอา
ไม่รู้คุณพ่อคุณแม่บอกเวลาเห็นดาวตกห้าม
สีครามสี
กลับมากลับมาอันนี้ของความเชื่อไทยแต่ใน
The  fifth  Element เนี่ยถ้าดาวตกเล็กๆ
คุณเรียนบอกชอบใช่ไหมคะถ้าดาวใหญ่ๆใหญ่ๆ
แล้วมันตกลงมา
ไม่ชอบ
ดาวใหญ่ๆแล้วตกลงมานักเรียนคะพอมามาลงมา
ใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่เทวดาละ
ดวงมาคือโลกรถเกิดอะไรขึ้นค่ะพี่เอ๋มันก็
จะ
ตูมเข้าไปก็จะแล้วก็เป็นก้อนหินที่นี่
เราเราเรียกว่าอะไรนะองค์เอาบางทีถ้าโดน
คนคนก็ตายถ้าโดนโดนต้นไม้ต้นโดนต้นไม้
ต้นไม้ก็ซึ่งอาจจะตายถ้าใหญ่นะใหญ่
port ดาวตกที่ลงมาแล้วโดนโลกพึ่งแล้วก็
ระเบิดขึ้นมาเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าอุกกาบาต
อุกกาบาตนะคะดาวตบใหญ่ๆใช่ไหมคะๆ
เรียกปูกระบะ
ก็ถ้าดาวตก
ดาวโต๊ะ
เกย์เวลาอะไรนะอ่ะในโลกอีก 300 ปีข้าง
หน้าเนี่ยค่ะโคเรียมถ้าเราก็คำนวณจะเกิด
ดาวตกจะเกิดปากไม่เลี้ยงดาวตกและเรียกกู
กาบาตอุกกาบาตใหญ่มาที่โลกโอ้โอถ้าโอกา
บาตมาที่โลกโลกก็จะแตก
ตูน
คนก็จะคนใช่ไหมคะให้ทำยังไงอ่ะ
ทำไมคัดเกิดอะไรขึ้นค่ะพี่เอ๋ในเรื่อง The
fifth  Element เนี่ยเราจะมีโรคแล้วก็มี
มีกาแล็กซี่อื่นมีดาวอื่นเราก็จะมี
อ่ะที่โลกเนี่ยก็จะมีมีดาวอื่นมามีดาว
ยูเรนัสที่อยู่ในนัดมีคนที่เนปจูนมีคนแต่
ว่าไม่ใช่คนรับเรา
เราเรียกว่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวมี
มนุษย์ต่างดาวนี้นะคะเขาไม่พูดว่า
เอเลี่ยนนะเขาเรียกมนุษย์ต่างดาวเหมือน
กับครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋เป็นคนไทยอยู่ประเทศ
ไทยถ้านะคะเหมือนคนอเมริกามาประเทศไทยก็
พูดว่าคนต่างประเทศ
นะคนต่างประเทศแต่ว่าอันเนี้ย
ในโลกอาจจะมีอเมริกาไทยญี่ปุ่นคิวบาเป็น
คนในโลกดาวโลกแต่ถ้ามีเหมือนคนแต่ไม่
เหมือนคนงงไหมมีแขนไหมคะนี่แขนอาจจะแขน
ยาวอาจจะหัวสูงๆๆ
อ่ะนะเราเราก็เรียกว่ามนุษย์ต่างดาว
อ๋อบางที่ดูเหมือนเราแต่ก็ไม่เหมือน
ในปีนั้นน่ะที่โลกมีมนุษย์ต่างดาวมามีมี
ดาวอนุชไปมามีเยอะที่นี้นะก็มีคำนวณว่าจะ
มีดาวตกที่เป็นอุกกาบาตใหญ่โอ้วทุกคนก็ทำ
ยังไงเดี๋ยวค่าพี่เอ๋ในปีนั้นมีมนุษย์
ต่างดาวมาคนมาเข้ามายังไงคะเข้ามาเดิน
เดินเดินมามั้ยคะไม่ๆเข้ามาด้วย
ยานอวกาศ
เราได้ว่ายานอวกาศ
ที่นี่เนี่ยกูเรียมก็มีมนุษย์ต่างดาวดี
แล้วก็ไม่ดีอ่ะมีเนื้อหนาก็มีดีไม่ดีก็จะ
มีมีโอกาบาตตกใช่ไหมอ่ะมีอันตรายก็มี
มนุษย์ต่างดาวอยู่คู่เอกจำชื่อไม่ได้อยู่
กลุ่มนึงอ่ะเขาเรียกว่าเป็นกลุ่มอะไรล่ะ
ปกป้องโลก
ใช่
อุบาทว์มาไม่ได้
อะไรก็แล้วแต่มีอะไรไม่ดีน่ะเขาจะมาครึ่ง
เขาก็จะมาจะมาเวลาที่โลกมีปัญหาเขาก็จะมา
แล้วก็
โอเคช่วยใช่มะปกป้องโลก
ของรถเค้าก็ไม่ได้อยู่ที่โลกเข้าอยู่
กาแล็กซี่อื่น
ไม่ได้อยู่กาแล็กซี่เดียวกับโลกค่ะอยู่
กาแล็กซี่อื่นแต่เขาจะมา
เขาก็มาหาพ่อเข้ามาปุ๊บเนี่ยยังถ้าเขารู้
ว่าเมื่อไหร่เขาก็จะมา
เขาก็จะเอา Element ที่ 5 เดี๋ยวมา
สิ่งหนึ่งที่ 5 ได้อะนิเมะนที่ 5 จะ
ปกป้องโลกคือภาษาไทยก็จะได้วัดท่าตะนะ
ธาตุที่ 5 คู่เอกมันคืออะไรอะไรอ่ะเขาก็
เอามาแปลว่าก็มีมนุษย์อวกาศมีอีกอย่างนึง
ไม่ดี
ยิงเขา
ทำไมคะทำไมต้องยิ้มก็อยากให้โลก
เขาไม่ชอบไม่ชอบโลกเหรอคะไม่ชอบทุกคน
เคยเห็นไหมคนไม่ดีแล้วไม่ชอบทุกคน
เอเลี่ยนไม่ดี
มนุษย์ต่างดาวที่นิสัยไม่ดีก็ไม่ชอบก็เลย
ทำให้ยาดีและมีปัญหาก็ระเบิด
[เพลง]
แล้วก็เหลือเชื่อแผนมั้ง
แขนอ่ะค่ะ
แขนของ
มนุษย์ต่างดาวอันเนี้ยที่อยู่ที่นี่
เป็นแขนแล้วที่แขนมีอะไรไม่รู้เป็นคล้ายๆ
แสดงให้เห็นว่าถ้า
คือ 5 ก็มีแขนเท่านั้นนอกนั้นระเบิดหมด
เลยระเบิดตูมหมดอันนี้ก็ตกมาที่โลกที่โลก
เขาก็เลยเอามาแล้วเขาก็จะมีห้องครัวเรียม
เขาจะเป็นแบบนี้เปิดแล้วเขาก็เอาแขนแล้ว
เนี่ยแขนใกล้ๆแขนเอเลี่ยนเนี่ยขึ้นใหญ่
มากเลยเหรอใหญ่ไม่ใหญ่นะก็ใหญ่อ่ะเราเขา
ก็ใช้ไม่รู้เทคโนโลยี Air การโคลนนิ่ง
โปรนิ่งอันนี้ปืน
กรนนิ่งเสร็จเป็นอะไรเลยไหมเป็นอะไรคะ
เป็นผู้หญิง
สวย
นี้
สวยที่พี่เอ๋บอกว่ามีผู้หญิงสวยอยู่คน
เดียวใช่ผู้หญิงสวย
ผู้หญิงสวยทรงจำให้ผมกราบนิ้ว
สวยมากเลยชอบมาก
เป็นผู้หญิงสวยคูเรียมไม่เป็นไรต้องให้
นักเรียนไปดูเองเออไปไม่ต้องให้ดูไม่ดู
ไม่หาพูดไม่ต้องหา
โอเคเป็นผู้หญิงสวยแล้วก็โอ๋มีแฟนชั่นไป
ดูเซ็กซี่มากๆ
ข้อนี้เป็นนางเอกคุยเฮ้ยทำไมมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวแขนน่ากลัวเปลี่ยนเป็นผู้หญิงสวย
แล้วผู้หญิงก็พูดไม่ได้อ่ะเอ้าๆกูอีกจำ
ชื่อไม่ได้นะดู 5 ครั้งจะจำชื่อไม่ได้เอา
แล้วก็ไปเจอเขาก็หนี
หนีอะไรคะพี่เอ๋ออกจากจากจากรัฐบาลตรงนี้
ก็หนีออกจากที่นี่หนีไปเราก็หนีไปเขาก็
กระโดดก็ไปเจิดแท็กซี่แต่เป็นแท็กซี่ที่
ไม่อยู่ที่ถนน
งานอันนี้เป็นซี่ยุทธแท็กซี่อยู่ในอากาศ
อะเนี่ยนาโค้ชนาร์โคสแท็กซี่ลอยอยู่
ก็กระโดดไปแล้วก็กูเจอแท็กซี่ที่เป็นอ่า
ผู้ชายก็ไม่หล่ออ่ะ
ขับแท็กซี่ไม่แต่ผู้ชายคนเนี้ยคิดว่า
เมื่อก่อนทหารมันเก่งมึงเก่งโอ้วก็จริงๆ
ตอนนี้ไม่มีอะไรอ่ะอ่ะนี้ไปนี้มาผู้ชายก็
เอาอะไรเนี่ยเธอเป็นใครผู้หญิงก็พูดไม่
ได้
ผู้ชายก็พาผู้หญิงไปที่บ้านแล้วครั้งกิน
อาหารแล้วก็ดูแลผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้ผู้หญิง
เป็นใครตอนแรกไม่รู้
ไม่รู้ผู้หญิงเป็นใครจน
อยู่ด้วยกันที่บ้านที่บ้าน 2 หาเพราะว่า
ผู้หญิงก็จะพูดประโยคนึงผู้หญิงต้องหาหา
หา
คนคนนึงอ่ะเป็นดาวอื่นเป็นมนุษย์อวกาศจาก
ที่อื่นมาใช่มะก็ต้องหาผู้ชายก็มีผู้หญิง
นะไปหา
ลูกผิดจำได้ไหมคะผู้หญิงพูดอ่ะผู้หญิงพูด
ไม่ได้อ้ะผู้หญิงพูดภาษาโลกไม่ได้ผู้หญิง
ก็ต้องเรียน
ผู้ชายก็สอนอันนี้กินนะอ่ะผู้หญิงอ่ะอ่ะ
อ่ะอ่ะอ่าแล้วก็เสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
ก็ที่กูเอกจำได้นะคือคือต้องไปหาคนคน
หนึ่งที่เป็นหัวโตๆร้องเพลงเพื่อเอาอะไร
สักอย่างหน่อยหาคู่เอกก็คิดอันนี้แหละเลย
แมนที่ 5 ใช่มั้ยฮะตัวเองคิดอ่ะ
แล้วใช่ไหมคะพี่
ปรากฏว่าอยากยังไม่รู้กูไอ้คิดอ่ะไม่รู้
ว่าอันนี้คืออะไรแมนที่ 5 เพราะพูดเพราะ
ว่าผู้หญิงสวยหาอันนี้ก็ได้ค่ะแล้วผู้
หญิงก็กลับมาบ้านผู้ชายแล้วก็มี
คอมพิวเตอร์ผู้หญิงก็เรียนเรียนเรียน
เรียนแล้วก็น้ำตาไหล
เรียนอะไรคะเรียนภาษาอังกฤษเป็นภาษาไทยสา
จาก YouTube
ผู้หญิงพูดได้หลายภาษาผู้หญิงเรียนแบบ
เร็วมากพอไม่ได้คอมพิวเตอร์ผู้หญิงเรียน
เรียนเรียน
ผู้หญิงก็เลยพูดภาษาอังกฤษได้พูดภาษาอะไร
ไม่รู้ได้เยอะมากเราผู้หญิงนะที่คุยจำได้
คือผู้หญิงน่ะร้องไห้ผู้หญิงก็บอกว่า
ฉันต้องช่วยโลกฉันใช่ไหมช่วยช่วยโลกไม่
ให้ระเบิด
วะทำไมฉันต้องช่วยโลก
ผู้ชายก็ถามผู้มีผู้ชายแกะผู้ชายพระเอก
น่ะเอาเป็นพระเอกใช่มั้ยใช่ขับแท็กซี่ผู้
ชายแท็กซี่เป็นพระเอกก็บอกต้องช่วยไงผู้
หญิงบอกนะทำไมฉันต้องช่วยโลกคือมีของมี
อะไรคบแล้วผู้หญิงก็บอกว่าทำไมฉันต้อง
ช่วยคนที่โลกน่ะยิงกันฆ่ากัน
ฆ่ากันมากๆทำไมฉันต้องช่วยโลกผู้หญิงใช่
คุณเรียมถ้าเป็นครูเรียมเป็นผู้หญิงคนนี้
สงสัยมั้ย
ใช่เล่มก็สงสัยทำไมช่วยทำไมก็คนที่อยู่ใน
โลกลูกข้าข้า
ยิงกันตาย
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เข้าใจผู้หญิงก็เสียใจจะมา
ทำไมทำไม
ก็เริ่มไม่มีแรงผู้หญิงเสียใจผู้หญิง
เหมือนๆจะตายก็ผู้ชายแล้วก็มีและมีอีก
ร้านหนึ่งสองสามอีก 3 คนก็เอาผู้หญิงไป
รู้สึกจะเป็นคล้ายๆปิรามิดอ่ะค่ะ
แล้วข้างในล่ะจะมีเตียงแบบนี้ครูเรียม
มีเตียงนอนอีก 2 คนมาจากไหนคะพี่เอ๋เป็น
เพื่อนของเป็นคนที่เป็นเพื่อนของผู้ชาย
เวลา
Story นิยาวมานักเรียนนะเนี่ยต้องไปดู
เองนะคะเพราะว่าจะตอรี่น่ะครึ่งชั่วโมง
เนี่ยพูดไม่จบครูเอกจะเอาคอร์ดที่ครูเอก
ชอบมาหมาก็คือผู้ชายก็เอาผู้หญิงมานอนที่
นี่อ้าที่นี่แล้วก็จะมีเสา
เสา
เสาเสาอยู่ 4 เสาร์หน้าเสาร์อันนี้ก็จะ
ต้องมีคนเนี่ย
ช่วยกันใช่ไหม 4 ๆ
คนน่าจะตีคนก็จะมีอันนี้อะไรอันนี้เป็น
บิลอันนี้เป็นนางนั้นอันนี้เป็นลมอันนี้
เป็นไฟ
เป็นธาตุ 4 ธาตุเป็นธาตุศรีธาตุชนะน้ำ
อันนี้น้ำเนาะธาตุน้ำน้ำลมคู๋ให้เป็นสี
เหลืองเนาะลมดมไปสีแดง
ทักไป
ดิอะนิดินพัด
ดินน้ำลมไฟศรีธาตุก็เป็นสาวที่ดินดินน้ำ
ลมไฟก็ต้องทำให้ตรงนี้มันมีพลังก็ทุกคนทำ
ยังไงทำยังไงสุดท้ายเขาก็รู้ว่าไม่รู้สึก
ว่าจะมีเหงื่อมั้งดีหรือลิ้นลมไม่รู้อ่ะ
ลมหายใจก่อน
มีลมหายใจตรงนี้ก็จะมีปิ้งขึ้นมาอ่า
ดินก็เอาดินเอาดินดิบดินที่นี่แล้วก็นอน
ใส่
อันนี้
[เพลง]
น้ำก็มีเหงื่อใช่ไหมที่นี่
ไฟนั่นแหละ
จุดไฟ
จุดไฟอ่ะก็คือจุดไฟปึ๊บไฟจะมาก็อันนี้ก็
ปิ้ง
อันนี้คืออันที่ 5
ยิ้มอยากรู้ค่าที่ 5 คือธาตุอะไรนั่นน่ะ
สิคุณเรียมคู่เตรียมคิดว่าอะไร
ถ้างั้นเนี่ยคือในเรื่องเนี่ยหอยเห็นปั๊บ
เนี่ยเราก็จะคิดว่าพอมีดินน้ำลมไฟเสร็จ
ถ้าที่หากระดับวุฒิอุกาบาตก็มาๆใกล้ๆๆๆๆ
เข้ามานะใกล้ก็บาทใกล้โลกมาก
ใกล้แต่ว่าอ่ะค่าที่ 5 จากกำลังจะตายฉัน
จะตายงั้นแล้วพอมีดินน้ำลมไฟทุกคนก็คิด
ว่าพอดินน้ำลมไฟขึ้นมาผู้หญิงจะต้องแข็ง
แรงเป็นซุปเปอร์ให้ผู้หญิงก็
ฉันจะตายอ้ะ
ไม่ทำอะไร
ผู้หญิงเอาต้องใกล้ๆทำอะไรล่ะผู้ชายก็
เข้าไปที่ผู้หญิงอ่ะ
เอาไปทำอะไรคะพี่เข้าไปอะไรนะ
ไม่มีสมมติก๋วยเตี๋ยวหมอนค่ะ
เป็นผู้หญิง
อันนี้หมอนใช่มั้ยเป็นผู้หญิงๆเอาผู้หญิง
โอเคขออภัย
อยากตายนะช่วยโลกช่วยโลกโอ้
มี
ผู้หญิงก็ถาม
ทำไม
ทำไมชั้นต้องปกป้องโลกก็ทุกคนฆ่ากันเอง
ใช่มั้ยคนคนที่โลกคนที่โลกมีบอมมีระเบิด
ฆ่ากันถ้าอุกาบาตมาก็เหมือนกัน
ก็ต่ายๆเหมือนกัน
ช่วย
ผู้หญิงก็ผู้หญิงเป็นยังไงคะ
เอกก็ตื่นเต้นมากเร็วๆก็บาทมาๆทุกคน
ด้วย
ผู้ชาย
ทำยังไงคะผู้ชายก็คิด
ก็จริงนะคนฆ่าคนทำไมเอเลี่ยนจะช่วยเรา
ทำไมมนุษย์ต่างดาวต้องช่วยเราแต่ผู้ชายก็
คิด
ไม่เป็นไรไม่ต้องช่วย
ผมรักคุณ
โอ้ย
คุยกันใช้เวลานานมากลืมคิดว่าอูกระบาดนิ
ทนโลกตายกันหมดเลยรู้จักเร็วมากกว่านั้น
คือผมรักคุณเพราะว่าคุณรู้มั้ยเพราะว่าผม
เนี่ยเหมือนกับอยากอยู่กับคุณเพราะว่ารัก
ผมรักรักคุณแล้วผู้ชายกับจุ๊บผู้หญิง
จุ๊บผมรักคุณอยากอยู่กับคุณผู้หญิงก็ตัว
ขึ้นแบบนี้แหละค่ะตัวผู้หญิงนะคะก็จะเป็น
แบบนี้
ตัวผู้หญิงก็เด้งขึ้นหลับแล้วค่ะอ่ะอ่ะ
มี
หน้าอกเค้าเค้าจะกลายเป็นตัวแบบแต่งงาน
ตำรวจเอาขึ้นมาพร้อมนะคะใช่ตัวเข้าไปลอย
ขึ้นจากผืน
แล้วก็มีแฟนอะไรขึ้นยี่แสงด้วยได้มีแสง
ขึ้นไปที่นี่แล้วก็
[เพลง]
ป้องโลก
อุกกาบาตมาพึ่งก็ระเบิดหน้าเราก็แสงอาทิ
มันขึ้นไปชนอุกกาบาตไว้ให้ระเบิด
เป็นเล็กๆไม่ลงมาที่โลก
บทที่โลกก็ไม่มีใครตายไม่มีใครปลาย Happy
Ending
คุณคุณหนังเบาะว่าเป็นคาดอะไร
นั่นน่ะสิภาพที่ 5  5 ตัวกูเองไม่บอกกู
เรียมไม่บอกให้ครูเรียมคิดแล้วคิดมากครู
เรียมมาบอกพี่เอ๋
[เพลง]
อุ้ย
ทำไมผู้หญิงสวยเป็นธาตุที่ 5 จริงๆถ้าที่
5 คืออะไรอันนี้มันมี mini มีอะไรซ่อน
อ่ะซ่อนเอาไว้เอ่อเป็นหนังที่แบบดูแล้ว
แบบหัวน้ำตาไหล
ที่อาบน้ำตากอะไหล่ดู 5 ครั้งก็น้ำตาไหล 5
ครั้ง
งงไปดู
คู๋บอกคนไปดู 10 คน
1 คนคนชอบทุกคนหนึ่งคนชอบเก้าจุดย่าง
ทำอะไรทำไมโกรธ
คู๋หนังไม่สวยสวย
ป่วยมันสวยมากแต่คุณต้อง
สวยที่นี่สวย
รวยที่ของสวยที่ใจ
ก็ไม่ได้สวยทีเด็ดนี้
เป็นหนังที่หลับสวยที่ความคิดสวยที่หัวใจ
กับทุกก้าวคนโปรด
อะไหล่
พูดหลอย
มาให้คุณเรียมเฉลยให้ครูเรียมดูคูเรียมดู
แล้วคุณเรียมค่อยมาบอกพี่เอ๋อันนี้ครูเอง
หินแต่ว่ากูเรียนต้องดูเองผู้เรียนจะ
คิดอะไรถ้าที่ 5
เรียมอาจจะเป็นคนที่ 10 ที่โกรธโหลด
จริงๆนะครูเรียมกูบอกว่าสิบคนหนึ่งคนชอบ
เจ้าคนโกรธนะแต่ครูเอ๋เราอันเนี้ยหลายๆ
ครั้งมีคนโกรธกูเอมมากกว่า 10 คน
ไม่มีการเตรียมก็โหลดผู้เรียนต้องไปดูค่ะ
ท่านดูได้กูลืมบอกเอ๋ตัวเองเนี่ยชอบ
ความหมายดีเป็นหนังที่ดีอ่ะดิมากค่ะนั่ง
ไม่สวยจะดี
เป็นนายคิดสวยมากความคิดสวย
ไปดูนะแล้วคุณลืมบอกตอนไม่ดู The  fifth
Element
ถ้ากูเรียนดูหนึ่งครั้งแล้วยังอะไรนะรู้ 2
ครั้ง 3 ครั้ง 4 ครั้งถ้าครั้งเหมือนคู๋
แล้วกูเรียนอาจจะชอบเพราะ
ทางและอะไหล่ดูหนึ่งครั้งแล้วอะไรแล้วก็
ดูสองข้างแล้วอะไรก็ได้ดู 5 ครั้งหรือ
เปล่า
นักเรียนต้องไปดูนะคะเดี๋ยวหนังเรื่องนี้
คือคือ Hollywood ไม่ได้ให้เงินครูเอ๋นะ
คะแต่ผู้เอกชอบเดินท่อแบบ
จริงอ่ะเออดูแล้วได้
ลายวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้ว
โอเคไปก่อนนะคะ
ตัวเองชอบมากชอบนักเรียนไปดูแล้วเข้าใจ
โอเคคุณจะโกรธกูเองคุณจะชอบคู๋คอมเม้นท์
บอกด้วยนะคะได้ค่ะ
ลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะสวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไม่วายส์